America's gun addiction is bad but to
understand just how bad it is you've got
to see the numbers in 2013 alone
American companies manufactured nearly
11 million guns only about 440 thousand
of those were exported on top of that
the u.s. imported 5.5 million guns
production of handguns rifles and
shotguns has risen steadily over the
past 15 years interestingly though the
number of gun deaths has stayed about
steady still the US has one of the
highest rates of gun deaths per capita
in the world at 10.5% a sliver below
Burundi a war-torn nation compare that
to our neighbors to the north with 2.1
deaths per 100,000 people Italy with 1.3
and Japan was 0.0 deaths
unsurprisingly US states with stricter
gun laws play host to fewer deaths by
gun shot on one end of the spectrum
we've got Massachusetts with strong laws
and about three gun related deaths per
100,000 people on the other Alaska and
it's weak laws with 20 and the frequency
and deadliness of mass shootings in the
US have spiked big-time over the years
check out the mid 90s compared to last
year
get over the same period of time support
for gun control has fallen the numbers
don't lie
clearly we've got a problem now it's
just a matter of finding a solution